A headline circulating around
says that eggs, meat and dairy
are essential for
brain development.
So what does this mean for
vegetarians and vegans?
Anthony, here, for DNews.
And on the sliding
scale of vegetarianism,
I'm kind of like
beginner to middle.
I'm a lacto-ovo
vegetarian, which
means I eat eggs and dairy,
but no other animal products.
And then on the
far end, of course,
you have vegans who don't eat
any animal products at all.
It's tricky to stay healthy
as a vegetarian or a vegan,
because you've always got
to watch what you're eating
and make sure you
get replacement
sources for everything you'd
normally get from an animal.
Except a new study from
the University of Montreal
is going around
online saying there's
a nutrient only found
in meat, eggs and dairy
that's essential for
brain development.
It's called asparagine.
It is an amino acid that we've
always considered an essential
to get through our diet.
It's one of the 20 most
common amino acids on earth.
Amino acids are used
to make the proteins
that you need to survive.
They're responsible for
strength, repair and rebuilding
inside your body.
The asparagine is mostly
involved with the development
and operation of your nerves.
Our liver actually makes a lot
of it out of other amino acids
automatically, enough to
provide for our whole body.
So here's where the study's
framing and headline sort of
fall apart, compared
to the actual content.
Even though just about all
of us make enough asparagine
automatically, there
is a small percentage
of the population with
a genetic defect that
causes them to not make as
much as everyone else, which
can lead to severe
intellectual disability
and even atrophy in their brain.
It just doesn't grow or change.
The headline seems to imply
that if you have this defect,
you will need eggs,
meat and dairy.
So a vegan or vegetarian
diet could be dangerous.
First of all, how
rare is this defect?
Well, so far only nine
children around the world
have been found to have it.
And in those
children, the addition
of asparagine in
the diet can help
boost the amount in their
body and get more of it
across the blood brain
barrier, which could counteract
the effects of
the genetic issue.
So it seems like being vegan
would only be dangerous
for those people, right?
Well, not even that.
See while the headline calls
out meat, eggs and dairy,
remember that asparagine is one
of the most common amino acids
on earth.
It's also in whole grains,
legumes, soy, basically
the staples of a vegan diet.
I love saying the word legume.
So if you're a
veggiesaurus and you're
seeing this story floating
around, and it got you nervous.
Don't worry.
Your brain is fine.
Well, as fine as it ever was.
I cannot speak for how
your brain was before.
Though if your
friends are like mine,
they think your brain is crazy
and the only cure is bacon.
And I don't think
there's any research that
will ever change that.
What food myths are floating
around that drive you nuts?
Is there anything you wanted
to know about food that you'd
like us to clear up for you?
Let us know down below, and
subscribe for more DNews.